we've arrived everybody at the end  of pride month for 2021.  i hope you had a really nice one i've  actually really enjoyed doing these  shorts  on specific topics to cover within the  lgbtqia plus community  a lot of questions that i know are  common and things of that nature  and i'd be happy to do a bit more i'm  going to take a break though because  like i'm going to run out of topics and  if it starts feeling like an obligation  i'll burn out on it but i have really  enjoyed it and if you have questions  things i didn't address  feel free to leave them in the comments  and maybe i will  maybe i won't even wait for the next  bride to roll around to address them  depending on what they are  i hope you had a wonderful pride i hope  that you have a wonderful rest of the  year  be you lgbtqia plus  or ally you are beautiful  you are valid and you are loved